-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Guys, I'm very excited
about this.
James Corden
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
He was supposed to be here
a few days ago,
but he took a carpool
all the way from L.A.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, since two
of the three late-night Jimmys
are in the same building,
Jimmy Kimmel is being locked
away in a secure location,
just so you know.
[ Laughter ]
I'm in a great mood
because we're right
in the middle
of the holiday season.
Christmas is almost here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Hanukkah starts on Sunday.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hanukkah is celebrated
for eight nights,
so the next time you complain
about your relatives
at Christmas,
times that by eight.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, people are still
shopping for presents,
and I heard that, this year,
one of the most unwanted gifts
is beauty products.
That makes sense.
You can't hand someone
a bag of make-up like,
"I thought you needed this."
[ Laughter ]
Well, in a recent survey,
for the second year in a row,
New Hampshire ranked
as the state
with the most Christmas spirit.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Vermont was like,
"Excuse me.
We have the
Ghost of Christmas Past.
Hello."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Last night, several
high-profile journalists
who have been covering Elon Musk
had their
Twitter accounts suspended.
Elon said the journalists
were using social media
to keep track
of what he's doing,
or as that's also known,
social media.
[ Laughter ]
I have a feeling that,
right after Christmas,
we're gonna see Elon Musk in
line trying to return Twitter.
[ Laughter ]
It's a big weekend for sports,
'cause this Sunday
is the World Cup final
between Argentina and France.
Argentina and France.
Of course,
my bracket's already busted.
I had England and Gonzaga
in the final.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Argentina versus France.
At first, I wasn't sure
what was at stake,
but then someone told me
it's like "Evita"
versus "Les Mis."
And I was like, "Oh, I get it."
[ Laughter ]
The final will be played
on Sunday at 10:00 a.m.,
so if you want to know
why soccer isn't more popular
in America, there's your answer.
[ Laughter ]
Well, everyone's
talking about this.
13 years after the original,
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
has finally hit theaters.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is wild.
The movie has a run time
of 3 hours and 12 minutes.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That's not a movie,
that's a flight.
[ Laughter ]
Even Hanukkah is like, "Whoa.
How long we doing this?"
[ Laughter ]
If this was on Netflix,
the "Are you still watching?"
thing would pop up 48 times.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, I'm still watching."
I read that, this weekend,
screenings of
"Avatar: The Way of Water"
are selling out
all across the country,
especially at IMAX theaters.
And I think I know why.
Check out this ad I just saw.
-You've never seen anything like
the underwater world of Pandora.
And in honor of
"Avatar: the Way of Water,"
IMAX has something else
you've never seen before.
Introducing FLYMAX,
the first large-format urinal,
designed to handle your stream
after a 44-ounce Icee
and a 3-hour movie about water.
Just zip and let 'er rip
as a cascade of blue liquid
take yours urine on
the adventure of a lifetime.
-Whoo!
FLYMAX, by IMAX.
Putting the "Aaa" in "Avatar."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that makes sense.
[ Applause ]
Some business news --
for the next three days,
Starbucks union members
will strike at 100 locations.
Yep, on the other hand,
that means the other
40,000 Starbucks will still
be open for business.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A Panera customer went viral
on TikTok after she discovered
that the chains
charged lemonade drink
contains more caffeine
than four espressos.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Panera was like,
"Well, you're gonna to need it
after eating a mac-and-cheese
bread bowl."
[ Laughter ]
After a few sips, she was like,
"Do you also hear EDM music?
Oh, never mind.
That's just my heart."
♪ En, en, en, en, en,
en, en, en, en ♪
[ Laughter ]
Guys, finally,
we have exactly one show left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ One day left ♪
-That's right!
For each of the last 12 shows
before Christmas, we've been
giving one lucky audience member
a magnificent Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
So since there is one show left,
let's open door number 1.
Where are we?
-It's right over there.
-Here?
-Right here.
-Go for it, pal.
Ready?
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
It comes with a hat.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Comes with a hat, too.
Wow.
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Now let's see --
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number -- if I
call your number, come on down.
Quest, could I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
238!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Come here!
Come on down.
♪♪
Yes!
Hello!
How you doing?
-Good. How are you?
-Nice to see you.
You can stand over there.
Hi.
What is your name?
-Mikayla.
-Mikayla, where are you from?
-I'm from Nashville.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nashville in the house!
It can get cool sometimes at
nighttime in Nashville, right?
-Yep.
-Do you have anything
like this at home?
-I don't think so.
-How about the matching beanie?
Do you have anything like that?
-Nope.
-Would you like to try it on
for our audience?
-Oh, of course.
[ Cheers ]
-Do you want me to hold
your glasses or you got it?
You can han-- All right.
Mikayla, good job.
Be careful.
♪♪
-Oh, perfect.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
-There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-[ Laughs ]
-Thank --
She wants to get out of it.
She's running away.
Bye, Mika--
Wow, look at Mikayla
going up the stairs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughing ]
She was running away!
"Thank you very much!"
Running away from me.
Yeah, it's like,
"Thank you, I'm so happy.
Thanks for the sweater."
[ Laughter ]
You know what, though?
You know what, guys?
I'm in the giving spirit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why --
Why does just one person
get a gift?
Why can't everyone
in the audience get a gift?
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right!
It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
-♪ It's "The Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away
an awesome gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
And we saved
the biggest gift for last.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Questlove,
can I get a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Tonight's Stocking Stuffer is...
a SONDORS Smart Step
ReCycled e-bike!
Higgins.
-That's right, Jimmy.
SONDORS refurbished Smart Step
is an easygoing e-bike
delivering convenient design,
tech, and performance,
while helping to maintain
a greener future
by keeping them out of
the landfills.
With its
easy-step-through frame,
the SONDORS
refurbished smart bike
is as fun as
it is effortless to ride.
Jimmy!
-Everyone's getting an e-bike!
Everyone's getting an e-bike!
Thank you, SONDORS!
Enjoy your gift, everybody!
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show"!